welcome to bananamores give it up
for one of my favorite alliterations
j jourdan hello
hey happy black history month
yeah i know it's not february but i
didn't come up with a stereotype
also if you celebrated black history
month i want to thank you
if you did not celebrate black history
month you might
want to change the channel like right
now
you might even want to turn the tv off
but i have bad news when you turn the tv
off the screen
will still be black i'm very happy to be
here i feel like i've come
full circle this time last year i was on
tv and this year i am
on my boyfriend's last nerve yeah no
kidding i'm on tv i'm on daytime tv i'm
very happy
to be a guy on daytime tv and not have
to worry about
a paternity test this is nice i'm
a millennial don't get too excited it's
just a fancy word for 30.
yeah i'm a millennial and people used to
make fun of us they used to say oh i'm
sick of these millennials
in high school millennials we aren't in
school we are in
debt we are in therapy we are in debt
because
of therapy or we're in therapy because
of the way that our debt makes us
feel i mean on the one hand we want to
be happy but in the other hand
we have our phones it's rough i don't
even like that term
millennial that's my generational cohort
it's because we grew up
during the millennium i don't know if i
like being named
after a backstreet boys album right i
don't know if
i want it that way and tell me why the
generations after us got such
cool nicknames you got ginzy don't make
fun of me
you got gin alpha then gen omega because
that's when the world ends bye bye bye
doesn't work and before us you had
generation
x and before them you had the baby
boomers and before them you had the
silent generation
which was named after the way that our
great grandparents had sex
just a whole lot of
was it good for you evelyn it was good
for me
i can make fun of older people because
the pandemic has turned me
into one i've definitely aged during the
pandemic
you can't tell because black don't crack
but it also
don't like being locked up i am at that
age where some of my friends
don't know their dads but also some of
my friends
don't know that they're that right i
am i'm old enough that i look
pretty good in a robe
is that trap like when you're 10 and you
wear a robe
people say oh look at him he thinks he's
a grown-up when you're 20
and you wear a robe people say what frat
are you in at my age people see me in a
robe and they just say we will
keep the music down mr jurgen we
understand it's late i'm like yeah it's
9 30.
that's a lot of commotion y'all are
keeping up i'm old enough
to use the word commotion correctly but
i'm not old enough
to enjoy baseball i'm not there yet the
other day i could tell i was getting
older because i walked outside i saw a
group of kids
outside of my building and the first
thing i said was young man
what are you doing pull your mask up you
look ridiculous
do you know what that means in prison
i like the kids i like the youths i
think they're doing a lot of stuff right
they know about all these different
activisms
and being socially aware they know about
intersectionality so if you don't know
intersectionality that's when you
hook up with someone at a four-way stop
the intersectionality
that is when you are more than one thing
at once like me
i'm black and i'm queer or as the
previous administration called it two
strikes maybe i do
like baseball uh but being black and
queer
it's interesting because it means that
sometimes when white women see me they
instinctively clutch their purse
but they have to compliment mine
thank you mj jourdain wow
the wowza wowza that jay jordan
knows how to work a crowd this next
comic is a banana maw's
legend please give it up for grace
writer
so growing up i watched a ton of
cartoons and
i found myself attracted to well a lot
of cartoon characters so i thought it
would be kind of fun
if we i don't know took a stroll down
memory lane and
recounted some of my old cartoon crushes
so in no particular order we have danny
phantom
and i like danny phantom because he had
white hair
super powers and he wore a spandex suit
really did not take much for me next we
have uh
number one or nigel uno from coding kids
next store
and i liked him because he had a fat
girlfriend
and she actually really looked like me
she had glasses and brown hair and was
fat and of course being insecure
growing up i was like nobody's ever
gonna love me even a cartoon character
but he was into fat girls so i was like
i could really see this working out for
both of us
so that was really exciting to finally i
don't know see me like representative
media
i guess i am white so i would whatever
but like the fat part
okay next we have simon from alvin and
the chipmunks
and he i liked him because
he had glasses again
very the bar's low bar's very low and he
wore a blue sweatshirt
and so and blue was my favorite color at
the time because i was like ew pink's
gross and
boys like the color blue and i'm kind of
like a boy cause i'm a tomboy and
i don't like skirts they're stupid so i
was really fun to be around
i think if i'm being honest like deep
down i really had a crush on alvin i
just
didn't want to admit it because i knew
like he would i don't know he wouldn't
be into me like that because
i don't know everyone's cool like the
whole name like the band is literally
alvin and the chipmunks like
i don't know it's like donald's but he's
like a total tool
anyways so it's i kind of dodged a
bullet you know elven
is the side thing the side hustle the
hook up the toxic
college boyfriend that you met on like
tinder or something
i say totally having gone to college for
only one semester and deleting tinder
after like
two seconds because i didn't want people
to like perceive me
but simon's the chip monkey marry so
whatever dodgeball
next we have nick wilde and i like well
because he
was a bad boy with a heart of gold he
was a criminal yes
which was also kind of hot too but he
didn't want to be a criminal he was only
a criminal
because that that's the cards he was
dealt with in life and he's like
hey like i'm nick wilde i'm different
like don't talk to me um he
like if he was a person he'd probably
wear like a black leather jacket or
something
and i don't know i was like he's
different like if
i got to know him i could change him you
know what i mean that's like the kind of
vibe i get from him and
you know you get to know him and you
realize yeah he's just a normal fox
and he's you know he he
built these barriers because life gave
him
these cards and he's do i keep going
with on the card thing but
you know what i mean anyways you can
change them as what i'm getting at but
you can't change elephant
but i can already see you guys right now
you're probably like wait a minute
zootopia came out in 2016. don't you
think
that's a little old to be liking a
cartoon fox be considering you were 16
when the movie came out
and to that i reply actually no that's
pretty normal i think it's totally
normal to have a crush on an
anthropomorphic fox
when you're 16 years old what else what
else am i going to do
this isn't euphoria okay
like normal teens have crushes on foxes
not whatever they do in euphoria um
next we have lola from shark tales um
she's a betta fish she's really hot
she's kind of like the jessica rabbit of
fish
yeah that's pretty much it she's
universally hot in the sense like
everyone thought she was hot
and last but not least we have elsa uh
the queen
the queen and i liked elsa for the same
reasons i liked
uh danny phantom she had white hair
super powers and although she didn't
wear a spandex suit she did have a
really tight-fitted dress with a slit in
it
and i remember in the theater when i
watched that i was like this movie's
pg-13
i don't think this kid should be she was
walking like
that was really great i was like i'll
think about that later
um but other than that yeah that's
pretty much
those are pretty much like obviously
that's not a comprehensive list if it
was
we would be here all day but that's just
a little taste
taste of my childhood crushes i can't
even get over how much talent this
person has
kind of unfair give a little to the rest
of us
i'm so excited to watch this next
performer light up
the bananamore stage get ready for
comedy greatness
hey banana morris thank you so much for
having me this is great i've been in
quarantine for a year
it is what it is i've been living with
my girl and it's been good
it's been good the universe kind of
brought us together aka
covet thank god she had her own place
um but i almost got kicked out three
times for hard eyes
i had to unlearn a lot of stuff you know
sitting hard eyes
you know how hard it is to try to
convince your girl that you and your
boys just hit hard
eyes now like babe we just sent heart
eyes over lebron that's just what we do
duh you need to get with it i only know
one person
that has enjoyed quarantine and that's
my brother
my brother has really enjoyed quarantine
because he has he just came home he was
serving
five years and i only say servant
because it sounds patriotic
but he was in jail and uh he was happy
to be home it was like a regular
you know he was like all right we
unlocked but i'm out and i'm happy for
him i'm happy my brother's home
i'm happy my mom got both her sons we
all hung out
and she could just stop hyping up every
little thing
like my brother did in jail you know
she'll call me should go
donald's reading and he's going to
church and he's going to the gym and
she'll go
why don't you go to church it's like duh
cause i'm not in jail
my brother looks great my brother looks
great
locked up five years he's got muscles
he's got abs
clear skin it's like he was locked up in
the whole foods
i need to find like a crime that's gonna
get me a one-year sentence so i can just
get abs thank you so much mitzi and
banana morse
mitzi banana mores
incredible i gotta watch that set again
let's rewind